لليوم الثالث على التوالي تشهد الاراضي
الفلسطينيه موجه من التصعيد هي الاعنف منذ
تولي حكومه نتنياهو زمام السلطه في
اسرائيل
قضوا برصاص الجيش الاسرائيلي في مخيم جنين
نهايه الاسبوع وبعدها بيوم واحد قتل سبعه
مستوطنين برصاص فلسطينيه في القدس
هذه المعركه وهذه المواجهه وهو لان هم ما
خلوا لنا شيء ولا واقع على الارض
الغربيه اللي هو 2002 و 2001 و 2003
انتشار المكثف للمستوطنين على الطرق
الرئيسيه في الضفه الغربيه
ومهاجمه المركبات الماره ومنازل
الفلسطينيين القريبه من الشارع
ترافقها دعوات وقرارات اسرائيليه
لتسريع وتكثيف تسليح المستوطنين
تجاوز المستوطنون حد مهاجمه المركبات
الفلسطينيه بالقرب من المستوطنات وتوغلوا
الى داخل الكره الفلسطينيه واحرقوا هذا
المنزل وسط مخاوف الفلسطينيين من تكرار
العمل وايقاع الضحايا ما قد يؤجج الاوضاع
اكثر من بلده الترمس خالد القاسم
العربيه